Um, super excited uh, to welcome Ted
today
uh, for our uh, guest spotlight. Um, Ted
Xiao is currently a founding member of
the technical staff at Project
Prometheus.
Um, previously uh, he was a staff
research scientist. Um,
and also a technical lead at Google
DeepMind on the robotics uh, team and
also the Gemini multimodal team. Uh, his
research agenda focuses on scaling
physical AGI in the real world with a
particular focus on approaches that can
leverage internet-scale foundation
models and methods that can improve with
more experience.
And uh, with this uh, we are very
excited uh, to hear from you, Ted.
Please give him a warm uh, welcome.
Thanks for having me uh, Oier and uh,
really uh, excited to to help kind of
share some uh, perspectives or uh,
showcase a lot of the progress that I've
seen over uh, the last decade or so in
robot learning um, and I think they a
lot of today will be historical, but I
think a lot of it will also uh, be
directly relevant. Uh, the past tells us
what the future will often hold and the
technology trends I think that have just
only accelerated and compounded are kind
of uh, the whole reason I would say many
times behind the entire hype and the
progress happening today.
Um,
to kind of set the stage for a kind of
like where a lot of the really exciting
work in robot learning happens, uh, I
think you can take a look back in
2015-2016
when really awesome breakthroughs uh,
you know, um, from from DeepMind like a
DQN or AlphaGo were happening. Um, the
those are the seminal works on the left
I think that inspired uh, kind of the
initial um,
that's in real-world robot learning
which was still kind of a very much so
unproven crazy idea. Um, but the
essential kind of founding thesis was
that we see all this immense progress in
you applying learning-based methods to
decision-making settings mostly in in
video games or or or board games like Go
or Atari, um, but on the other hand we
actually did already have at that point
uh, you know, electromechanical systems
of robots that you know, were still pale
in comparison to what we have today, but
you know, they were able to you know,
have this like quite famous that demo
from a few decades ago at Stanford where
they were able to remote teleop this
mobile manipulation robot to actually go
and clean up this living room or fetch
you a beer from the kitchen. Uh, this is
the technology for this the hardware had
already existed for quite a bit now. It
was just the intelligence that was the
bottleneck. The the the generality of
uh, the the actual performance a system
that could operate in many conditions
completely autonomously. And so the idea
was like if the hardware is like you
know, almost ready or it's it's it's
definitely close to there, um, but the
intelligence is not, but then you do
have these intelligence breakthroughs in
the digital domain, can you kind of
explore the intersection of these two?
And that was kind of the founding thesis
of uh, the Google Brain team and and
quite a few other organizations at that
time and I think that kicked off the
first era that I'll talk about today
which is the era of existence proofs
starting from around 2015-16-17
up until I would say about 21. Um, and
and for each of these eras I'll maybe
highlight some of the works that I felt
really defined kind of the the vibes
during this time. Um, some of the
technical work kind of the thought
behind it and the kind of results and
and and the questions that were evolving
during that time. Um, most of the work
I'm talking about uh, today is just is
from uh, Google DeepMind or Google Brain
uh, just because that's where I had the
most intimacy uh, of the you know,
understanding what was going on, but of
course during this time there's tons of
interesting work happening all around
the world in so many different labs and
different um, you know, groups, um, but
and uh, I'll I'll
touch upon some of those at the end.
So, circa 2016, right? DQN, AlphaGo, uh,
Google Brain just had the idea of like
what if we just bought you know, half a
dozen a dozen uh, you know, very
expensive robots. Every academic lab
only had maybe one. What if we just had
uh, you know, quite a few of them, put
them in a room, have them collecting
real-world experience for picking up
various objects and bins and then we
just try to figure out kind of what this
environment looks like, what this MVP
looks like, uh, what uh,
and figure out the operations behind it
and because we're just going to be
investing a ton of resources into this,
let's see if we can just scale things up
and get things to learn. Um, this was
you know, maybe you've seen some of
these images uh, you know, that look
like the left and the middle. These arm
farms where you just have a bunch of
robots uh, a bunch of Kukas together uh,
picking up data uh, picking up different
objects, collecting large-scale data
sets um, mostly through some kind of
autonomous exploration policy or some
kind of off-policy learning on-policy
learning. Um,
that started working a bit. There were
definitely things that worked well. Some
things that were a bit trickier, uh, but
it worked well enough that you know,
ambition to scale to multitask learning
a single policy that could actually
understand and execute different tasks
different skills in the real world
became a very strong goal. Um, and that
later then you know, spread beyond just
the single bin to a single table to
maybe a whole lab, right? Still a kind
of structured environment, but you know,
we can mock out this kitchen-like
setting you see on the right um, and
that was like the era of where we were
really scaling up these offline data
sets.
Um, it's to touch upon some of the work
from this era, right? We can we can
start from this first one of like the
initial first arm farms, right? Where
can we even do end-to-end robot learning
in the real world? Is this crazy idea
something that's even possible? Um, here
it was a lot of stuff like setting up
these robots, putting them in a room,
instrumenting them, uh, making sure that
the deployment data collection and eval
would work properly, taking the kind of
methods that work well um, let's say
DQN, right? Uh, you Q-learning is pretty
powerful. Learning value functions and
value-based RL was really interesting,
but with robotics things got trickier
with high-dimensional continuous action
spaces. So, how do you do that? Um,
you're not you're not you're not doing
tabular Q-learning anymore. How do you
learn over a continuous value function
over a continuous state and action
space? What happens when your
observations are now higher-resolution
pixels? How do you do that? Um, so the
one of the the foundations of this works
of what was called QT-Opt um, which was
basically how we can apply the idea of
Q-learning to robotics where we ran out
of this you know, arm farm had more than
500,000 grasps and structures which was
quite a bit at that time um, and then
and then training with off-policy and
and and as well as on-policy online
rollouts, figuring out how to do that.
Um, we also explored ways of evaluation.
So, this RL CycleGAN work was a was kind
of like an OG um,
real-to-sim real and real-to-sim
evaluation protocol where we would we
would have a digital twin of grasping
various objects in sim and this is still
the era of spice of of GANs. So, style
transferred and turned the sim images
into realistic images uh, so that we
could then kind of eval in a
realistic-looking simulation. So, to the
policy whether it was evaluating in the
real world or in sim, ideally it was
pretty agnostic and the sim evaluations
could be a good signal.
Um, we also were looking at you know,
the full stack of not only do we treat
this um, robotics domain as uh,
quasi-static where you can pause
anytime, the real world is is dynamic.
So, if you want fast reactive uh,
dynamic-looking robot trajectories, you
also need to think about how to do kind
of policy execution and learning
concurrently with uh,
um,
your your inference time.
Uh, the the next brief kind of batch of
results was uh, when we were really
thinking about okay, great. This QT-Opt
thing, this real-world off-policy RL
seems promising. How do we scale that
up? Um, how do we get better
performance? How do we get learn many
tasks? This was definitely not easy um,
and we were starting to hit I would say
the bottlenecks of kind of what's
challenging about these like real-world
large-scale RL uh, flywheels. Um, and
and so we started exploring a variety of
different methods especially betting
larger on imitation learning. With
BC-Zero we collected a quite a large
teleoperated data set uh, on on this uh,
you know, one-arm mobile manipulation
robot um, from Google X um, from
Everyday Robotics uh, and then trained a
language-conditioned behavior cloning
policy. We also looked at how these
kinds of imitation learning methods
could play well with RL, right? Get the
best of both worlds. Maybe you you start
out with uh, you know, bootstrapping
from expert data imitation learning and
you transition to this like online
self-improvement uh, you know, a reward
function-based RL regime. How do you do
that? Um, we of course also just took
the thing that kind of worked QT-Opt and
scaled it up to multiple tasks MT-Opt
multiple tasks QT-Opt.
Um, and finally I think we also started
exploring uh, more novel algorithms uh,
of like how you could scale up the
generality or diversity of the data
distributions of training over. Um,
learning from play was one of these
works where we just thought okay, what
if instead of collecting this very real
task-specific RL rollout or this you
know, expert giving uh, you know,
trajectories of of teleop, maybe you can
just have experts just play around in an
environment for you know, a very very
long period of time. Then you use this
very unstructured ungoal-oriented data
to actually extract useful general
[clears throat]
um, you know, task-specific skills from
that. Um, and and so these are all kind
of I would say just just the next batch
of works that took the foundations that
were established in this first era arm
farms and then scaled them up a bit
more, explored different ways to apply
them.
And I think at the end of this uh, kind
of you know, a section where we were
okay, these all kind of work, can we
scale them one step further? A lot of
folks we had this like really big idea
of like okay, what if instead of like
these incremental scaling, we just
started over from scratch. We have this
new robot at the beginning of COVID, uh
can we just invest now a year, year and
a half on this really, you know,
interesting bet of building out a large
contracting team, having a much larger
fleet of robots, and then they're just
all collecting demonstrations in the
same environment, um where our goal is
not to solve one task or 10 tasks or 20
tasks, but hundreds or thousands of
tasks. Um and and that's what we did. We
set up the operations, we scaled up this
data collection effort, and to my
knowledge, this is one of the largest uh
expert demo collection uh kind of
projects, um and it was happening for
over a year and a half on on many robots
in the environments you see here. These
are now all learned policies, but uh you
know, going from, you know, this very
wide uh large-scale diverse distribution
of of training uh into this like more
open-world evaluation setting was, you
know, kind of a big lightbulb moment for
for many on the team. Um
and I think around when that data set
started getting ready with the
operations started getting the risk,
that's what I would call like the
beginning of the era of foundation
models. Because while we were doing all
this stuff, right? Like like the the the
the the QT-Opt, the the BC-Zero, all of
these explorations, at the same time our
neighbors and our peers in the language
modeling world started to, I think a lot
of the breakthroughs there really
started to scale, right? Uh this was,
you know, GPT-3, 3.5, InstructGPT, it
was uh you know, the era of Palm of of
um LaMDA, it was the era of ChatGPT. Um
and and you could see when you did train
on an internet scale of different tasks
and data distributions on Wikipedia and
Reddit, and when you did kind of treat
everything as, uh you know, if if you
can ask for it, maybe the language model
has a chance of doing it, um depending
depending on prompting. All of these
trends kind of were like really really
picking up steam, and and so I think in
the robotics world, we started to think
about it seems like this new magical
alien technology of foundation models
and and and internet scale, you know,
next token prediction seemed to be
really taking off. How can we leverage
those models themselves or even ideas of
these models that drive these models to
create foundation models for robotics?
Um and I'll and I'll talk about some of
the highlights here. Um I think if you
just look um at what makes foundation
model work, we could break these into
different components. Uh so there's
quite a certain design principles of
treating everything as tokens, or
there's the certain idea that like you
can leverage pre-trained representations
or pre-trained models entirely because
the capabilities they showcase are
general, all right? You can leverage
foundation models as components, a part
of a larger system. And there's also the
idea that, you know, we went from online
R farms, which were, you know, pretty
powerful, the idea of autonomous
self-improvement, but in practice were
very difficult because of uh you know,
the fact that on-policy online data
collection would was very costly in
terms of uh robot time and and and and
human kind of maintenance um of managing
these data distributions. If you could
switch to this more offline learning
setting that the rest of ML and
supervised learning was kind of leading
into, uh could we do that? So that was a
bet on collecting large-scale behavioral
cloning expert demonstrations, where it
didn't really matter that the the expert
demo was not collected by your policy,
the fact that it was just, you know, the
golden standard oracle behavior uh was
quite powerful, and uh leveraging like
uh economies of scale, so to speak. So
if you combine these components, right?
The design principles, the large offline
robot data sets, and leveraging existing
foundation models, which operate mainly
over language as a substrate, you get
this kind of like potential recipe for
how you could create a robot foundation
model um kind of in-house or from
scratch. Um this was Robot Transformer
1, RT-1. Uh this was where we took
different performance components, uh a
very strong uh vision encoder, uh Vision
Net, um and with film cross-attention,
uh token learner, uh transformer, um
uh backbone to kind of get to this
tokens in tokens in out world, where we
have RGB images, we have a language
instruction, and then we generate uh
different robot actions represented as
discretized tokens. Um
uh and and uh
all of these design decisions, you have
tokenized input outputs, you have
decoder-only uh architecture, you have
an image tokenizer, and and and you use
kind of some kind of more intelligent
like quantization almost or or or or or
compression of of action tokens. These
ideas, when you put them together that
were inspired by kind of all the
progress happening in broader ML, you
combine them into one model, we got this
like first general-purpose uh robot
transformer, which could do hundreds of
tasks, um you know, using imitation
learning at like, you know, pretty
reasonable performance, not perfect
maybe
between 60s and 80s, um but it was very
interesting because it was like the
first attempt at, you know, just taking
from first principles a lot of the kind
of uh bleeding-edge trends, scaling up
to 35 million parameters, running at 3
Hz, um and this was kind of like a
first, I would say, existence proof and
a a a a a
showcase of what these kind of concepts
could give you.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
but at the same time, right now that we
had RT-1, this like general backbone,
we're also thinking of, "Great, we had
to do a lot ourselves, that we had to
adapt these models, you had to rip them
from pre-trained models and combine them
like, you know, Frankenstein in a lab."
It also seemed that these models by
themselves were extremely powerful. For
example, language models, right? They
were already starting to show that they
could they would hallucinate a lot, but
they would still sometimes directionally
get common sense reasoning down, they
would have some physical intuition, it
wasn't perfect, but was there a way that
we could leverage that for, you know,
robotics? Um one idea was that, "Okay,
great, they can give you like a plan of
like, please put an apple on a table."
Great, break it down into a plan, what
would you first do? What's the order of
operations that you should be doing? Um
you could send out that that that kind
of prompt to an LLM and look at what its
completions were being and look at, you
know, the the kind of uh log probs that
would give you, and that's kind of what
you see the numbers on the on the left.
Um what's important though then is
actually grounding that in what your
robot policy, RT-1 in this case, could
actually do. Um and here we we we we
trained a value function, a Q function,
um on top of uh
um our our RT-1 uh that would tell you
kind of like for each of these
instructions in my current state, uh how
likely is it that I can actually
accomplish it. And this was a nice way
then to kind of uh
importance way or or kind of combine
what the language model thought was
important based on their log probs with
with the robot policy that was actually
doable, feasible, um via its kind of
internal value function. And and by
combining these then, you could then get
plans that were more grounded. Like
maybe a language model would say, you
know, picking up the apple's good, but,
you know, the robot policy knows that's
not possible right now, I first even
navigate and go find an apple. And so by
combining these two worlds, uh we kind
of got the first collision of uh using
language models just completely off the
shelf and putting that into a uh
combined robotics system uh for planning
long-horizon tasks, breaking them down
into intermediate subgoals that RT-1
could then complete.
Um there were other ways to use um
foundation models as well. Uh one way
was data augmentation. Uh RT-1, the data
set that we collected, uh was by these
days standards tiny, it was uh 87,000
trajectories collected over a year and a
half, um but the instruction diversity
was actually not quite large. Um and so
the idea was, could we use a VLM for
synthetic generation to relabel uh kind
of these episodes as different tasks
that could have been feasible? Can we
relabel them, create a much larger data
set, and then uh now we can retrain RT-1
on this much more or rich language
language distribution. This is very
similar to these days how uh models like
image generation models or or video
models like VIO are trained, a lot of
synthetic captioning that kind of uses
data to distill in and arbitrage what
the VLM has learned, but what your data
set did not contain.
Um
and then, you know, beyond just taking
LLMs for sake and or VLMs for dial, uh
we also started thinking about, "What if
instead of expressing these foundation
model benefits in arbitrage via data,
what if we just made them the backbone
itself?" Um and and so this was kind of
a project called RT-2, where we explored
a regime of, you know,
vision-language-action modeling. If you
take a VLM, and which is trained on on
tasks like you see on the middle, like,
you know, captioning what is happening
in this image or uh different language
tasks, um could you also just treat
robot action prediction as a visual
question answering task? Given an image
and given this certain kind of, you
know, what should the robot do to, you
know, whatever, um close the drawer, uh
then can you just respond in language
tokens that can get then get decoded to
actions? Um and and could you then scale
this up the same way that VLM backbones
have exhibited very powerful scaling
laws.
Um we tried this on on various VLMs,
Poly X and PaLM-E, uh and we and we
mixed kind of, you know, 50/50 with
internet data, with robotics data on the
same RT-1 data set, and we found that
this VLA paradigm was actually quite
powerful, and you were able to transfer
a lot of concepts from this internet
distribution around what new objects
are, around common sense reasoning,
around maybe recognizing even written
text, a lot of things that you we
wouldn't necessarily have expected
because we never collected these kinds
of information in our robot data set,
but because they were in this internet
distribution, and we were always
co-fine-tuning, um this had a very good
transfer properties when we were
measuring generalization of VLAs to many
new kind of out-of-distribution
scenarios.
Um
and another project here was the Open
Cross Modal Agent project, which which
was I I view as a seminal existence
proof of whether or not you could one
coordinate, like, you know, a
institutions around the world, more than
30 research labs, kind of combine all
the data that's been collected for
various projects, combine that data now,
and then see if you could learn
something new from it. Make Could you
Could you expose it, clean that data,
make it easy to kind of, you know, train
on, and and and and could you start to
see then, uh, you know, this kind of
motion uh knowledge transferring between
different robot morphologies, even
though the data was collected by
different people for different use cases
on different robots around the world?
Um, during this time, too, I would say,
uh, um, and I I think this is one of the
the last ones of the era of foundation
models is now that you do have these
very strong existence proofs, RT1, RT2.
You have large-scale datasets, and you
have foundation models really maturing
very fast. Uh, right? Um, new new new
models are dropping every week uh that
were very smart. Could you use these
better for robot robotics field? RT2 is
just kind of existence proof. If you did
it this one way of just, you know,
casting robot actions to strings
essentially with some smart tricks, like
could could this ever work? And the
answer was yes, this could work. So,
now, you know, I think a new interesting
research area was, are there better ways
to combine robotics and express them for
VLMs or VLA training? Are there better
ways of representing robot actions and
physical motion? Um, and we There was
quite a few that we explored um at
Google DeepMind ranging from
object-centric segmentation masks all
the way to hierarchical language where
you break down a longer horizon
instruction into shorter horizon
substeps um looking at actual
affordances, grasp angles and grasp
angles and key points, or even
trajectories um which were you know,
just from an egocentric view.
But, I think uh you know, all of this
work was happening at immense velocity
from 2021 all the way maybe to 2024 or
early 2025, I think clearly in the last
year and a year or two, um, there's been
tremendous amounts of investments and
energy and excitement in the into the
idea that maybe these existence proofs
that we saw, maybe the initial early
foundation models, VLAs, this technology
is is actually enough to generate real
value, to actually put uh crazy amounts
behind, and actually go and try to
commercialize. Or or if you want to do
more fundamental research, you need to
scale this research needs to happen at
order of magnitude or more higher. Um,
and and I think this era of scale um
kind of led to quite a few works up
until the present day, um, as well as a
few directions which which I'll be
highlighting. Um, so the first of which
is, you know, to cap off off some of the
work that would happen most recently at
Google DeepMind, um, after seeing the
promises of RT2, of RT1, of this like
this kitchen multi mobile manipulation
kind of domain, uh, there was a huge
transition on the team to, okay, these
foundation models that we're using, Palm
and Polly, were quite interesting, but,
you know, Gemini has been in a league of
its own as a very strong multimodal
frontier model. Uh, right? Um, and and
and in addition, uh, there was kind of
this hardware trend that Aloha, this
bimanual Aloha platform where you
puppeteer uh was giving you much higher
data throughput at much higher quality
where you could learn much more of
dexterous behaviors. Um, and so this is
kind of showcasing a project called
Gemini Robotics which was released
around March of last year that combined
kind of this like embodied reasoning,
the world knowledge of Gemini 2.0, and
then taught it how to do immense amount
of diverse robot actions on the Aloha
bodyment um that showcased a state of
the art in dexterity and be able to
post-train to new bodyments like the um
the uh Unitronics humanoid on the right
or this um you know, Biomech Franka
setup um as well as exhibit kind of like
compositional generalization around
reasoning at test time.
Uh, this quickly followed a few months
later with Gemini Robotics 1.5. Once
again, it had two parts, the body
reasoning part, the VLM, the through the
reasoning part, as well as the actual
VOA, the the action prediction part. And
here the focus was on on on two things.
One was on thinking, uh, so leveraging
kind of language-based reasoning at test
time uh to to to exhibit kind of chain
of thought. As well as the second way
was uh was called motion transfer, which
was like um
uh no longer needing to post-train to
adapt to specific embodiments, rather
than um training with all these
embodiments, the Aloha, the Biomech
Franka, and the the humanoid together at
pre-training time with a shared action
space. Um, this is very powerful because
that a single policy, a single neural
network could then control all these uh
robots simultaneously without any
specific fine-tuning needed.
But, then, you know, to to then step
away from the work that was being done
in Alphabet at Google DeepMind, a lot of
things are being scaled down, and a lot
of great work was happening across the
industry and academia. Um, model
generality and performance is getting
scaled, robotics data is getting scaled,
and I think research directions, the
entropy in the research environment is
also kind of unprecedented at the
moment.
When you look at model performance, I
look to really awesome work coming out
of folks like a pie or or or generalist
or or Dyna, you can see learning from
experience, adapting, post-training has
been a very, you know, increasing trend.
Um, I was very impressed by the pie 0.6
paper that was looking at, you know, how
you could, you know, really learn these
longer horizon, very dexterous, precise
tasks like espresso making. Um, I I
think uh that was really cool to see.
Um, uh you know, for generalization is
also another type of model performance
that isn't just like how What's your
end-end success rate, rather how robust
are you to changing distributions? Um, I
think here, uh, you know, the Google
DeepMind team was spending a lot of time
and on this and show and seeing very uh
you know, very strong results on the
ability of the Gemini Robotics uh VLAs
to generalize to all these new
situations. Um, and now that we do have
so much energy in this space, right? A
lot of uh players that are putting out
really cool foundation models on many
different types of robots, just
comparing how the field is advancing in
terms of our knowledge and our
capabilities has become a challenge
where a lot of these real-world rollouts
have required thousands or even tens of
thousands of trials just to validate and
get statistically significant samples of
performance or AB tests.
Um, so there's also really cool work
happening in the scalable evaluation
space, whether it's happening in Sim
with the with the top picture um or
whether it's in these decentralized
distributed evals like uh RoboArena on
the bottom.
For robot data scaling, too, I think
this is also one of my probably the
biggest buzzwords these days. So, like
there's no robot of uh you know, there's
no internet of robot data. Can we scale
that? Um, maybe in the last era, the era
of foundation models, a lot of scaling
was happening both in-house, right?
Berkeley would collect a large dataset,
Brace dataset, um and then maybe the
Google DeepMind team would collect
collect large datasets for uh the uh the
one-armed mobile manipulator or for
Aloha. But, these days, you know,
there's a lot more embodiments. There's
a lot more types of data distributions
that people are targeting. How do we
scale that up? And there's really big
bets that are happening now. They're not
necessarily mutually exclusive, but they
are quite opinionated and different. You
have this co-design of hardware, data
collecting, and and the model out of
players like, you know, Sunday Robotics
or Generalist are really getting good at
this like UMI-like scale-up um at at at
at a global footprint, right? That you
can just ship these devices off all
around the world, and it's very easy for
humans to put on these gloves and
collect data.
You also have, you know, maybe you skip
the glove entirely. You just collect
hand data. You scrap You scrap um strap
a GoPro or an iPhone on someone's head,
and you collect uh you know, egocentric
data or or or or or glasses. Um, and
this is also, I think, a huge rising
trend. And and finally, maybe a very
important part of a data distribution at
scale is the in in the wild data,
deployment data.
Um, and and to wrap it up, I think this
is my last slide. Uh, I think the
science is also getting scaled. There's
so many interesting scientific
questions, really big bets that are
being played, right? What is the
importance of world models for data or
evals or even as a backbone, right? I'm
really excited by world action models, a
lot of the the immense progress
happening on Dreamer 0 particularly is a
very impressive paper. Um, robot-free
data that I mentioned, this is getting
scaled up immensely, but there's so many
important research questions of like,
what are the pros and cons of this data
compared to expensive, high-quality
teleop data? We see a lot of thinking
models with RLVR and and and
post-training and reasoning happening in
language modeling that's driving things
like ejected coding. How do those ideas
kind of percolate and project into
robotics? And finally, I think a big
elephant in the room here is a lot of
work all the work I talked about today
was about manipulation, dexterous,
general-purpose manipulation, but it's
clear that, you know, for locomotion,
for balance, for whole-body control,
there's a lot of what happened in Sim to
Real in in in Sim to Real with RL that's
seeing immense progress in Robots are
dancing, they're doing kung fu, they're
recovering, they're moving with very
high amounts of extreme agility, and
that's not happening via imitation
learning. That's happening through a
very other kind of learning paradigm.
How do you unite what we're seeing in
manipulation with what we're seeing in
locomotion?
With that though, I'm uh you know, I'm
happy to to to end here. Um, I think
that if I had to just summarize this
10-year journey that in sentence is, we
I think as a field, we've made more
progress than many of us would ever
thought would be possible in our
lifetimes, but now there's more open
questions and uncertainties and open
frontiers than ever. So, I think the the
area of robotics research is both more
critical and closer to fruition than
ever, but there's also never been so
many like uh you know, composing
opposing beliefs and opinions and and
and open research ideas where we are
really entering kind of a new era of of
research. So, with that though, I'm
happy to take any questions. Thanks.
>> [applause]
>> Thanks so much for the great talk. Any
questions from the audience?
Okay, I see one in the back.
What do you think the role of
high-quality teleoperation data will
look like in the future? Will it just be
absolute end tuning, or do you think it
will still be crucial in the
foundational level of the models?
Yeah, great question. Um, you know, a
question about the the role of real
world teleop data. You know, is it going
to be fine tuning or else elsewhere? I
think again, this is I would say this is
a huge um
open question, right?
Of like um
whether or not
currently, right? I would say over the
last few years, real world teleop data
has been the golden standard. It is the
bread and butter of most good perform
policies today. Where it's like because
data quality has been so hard to
quantify in robotics that the safe bet
was just to max out data quality by
doing it in house with your own
operations team or your own students who
are very close to the model can also
figure out whether it is good. I think
we are shifting now. I I I think
we are now in a place where the burden
of high quality data is starting to get
externalized, right? To to to you know,
distributions that are very different
from your target test time deployment.
Whether or not this is going to continue
I suspect this will probably continue. I
like Anuka from Nvidia has this Nvidia
has a data pyramid where maybe you start
with internet data and sim data and and
maybe non-robotic video data. Then you
finally the pyramid on top, you know,
the cherry on top is the fine tuning
data. I think this is a very likely way
that the world will trend. The timelines
though are what I'm not sure of. If this
pyramid takes a decade to solidify
before we really understand how to
collect very like, you know, sub-optimal
crappy general data, but then we learn
how to leverage it properly uh so that
we only need this tiny cherry on top of
real data, that would be great. We're
going to get there. If it takes 10 years
though, that means that in the meantime
it's probably better to prioritize
really high quality teleop data. Maybe
you just turn that towards a
distribution you want. I think there's
players who are doing that, right? Who
are really looking at the deployment
distribution, the long tail data as the
mode. They just want them they don't
care that the their method their method
isn't scalable. They just want the best
data possible on this really rare data
in human homes, in a workplace, on the
assembly line, in the wild, right? On at
the job site. So, I think that's
definitely for sure going to be very
powerful in the next year or two, but if
this pyramid of, you know, general
purpose sub-optimal data collection at
huge diversity, if that research gets
unlocked in the next year or two, then I
would say the role of teleop data kind
of diminishes a lot. If that research
takes longer, then I think teleop is
still king.
Thank you.
Yep, we have a second question.
Um do you think that video action models
will be the next big thing like having
uh the backbone learn the physics itself
instead of just like putting everything
on uh
the robot data
um
and overloading it? And do you think
that and what do you think about um
working in latent space instead like uh
recent V-JEPA like 2.1 and combining
those?
Yeah, great question. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
video models world models video world
action models are are are these the next
big thing? Um I think in a nutshell,
yes, absolutely. I I think I think the
properties that change when you really
leverage the priors that don't come from
language, VLAs, VLMs, most of their
capabilities come from language uh from
text. But then when you switch then to
large scale video based pre-training,
the priors you learn around time and
space and, you know, intuitive physics
are just so different and and often
times beneficial. Things that are very
hard for text based pre-training to do,
maybe video pre-training gives you for
free. Um I'm very impressed by all the
results. It's very intuitive why this
makes a lot of sense. I think every year
almost for the past few years everyone
someone has tried to do this. I think
now is maybe finally the time where
where where, you know, video models, the
the infra, the the pre-trained policies,
the knowledge of like what it takes to
train great video models, all of that is
kind of there now where maybe we're
ready to consume this technology in
robotics.
That being said though, you know, I I I
think um
the question of whether or not this is
the final thing. Like will will we just
replace VLAs with video action models
world action models and then we don't
look back?
Um I'm not sure, right? Or do we need
something that's the best of both
worlds? I I say that because if you look
at the existence proof in our other
domains, in knowledge work, in in
language models, and even in like native
image generation like Dana Banana, a lot
of that capability is driven by text.
Text is, I think, extremely powerful
because of the amount of priors that we
we get for free. You're starting from,
you know, very, you know, high amounts
of reasoning when you kind of distill
the internet and this really helps you
kind of raise up all of the modalities.
So, Dana Banana Pro will take a lot of
time reasoning. Same with, I think, some
of Open AI's native, you know, image
media generation models, they will be
actually thinking in text space even if
they're predicting in a modality that
looks like pixels or audio or something
like that. So, if the same type of text
based reasoning that allows us to prove
new math proofs actually transfers
somewhat to robotics, that I think you
would still need a substantial amounts
of
exposure, I think, to text. Which
current video models look more like, you
know, they they understand the intuitive
kind of high frequency details of
pixels, but, you know, VIO by itself
before it's kind of fused with Gemini is
not a super smart text reasoner. So, I
think it really depend I think it's
actually on a rising trend. I think
we'll see really cool progress that
we've never seen before, but is this the
final recipe? I'm not really sure. I
still like text for many reasons, but
but of course I think getting the best
of both worlds will be closer to the
answer.
Um what about mobile manipulation? Do
you think we're going to have some kind
of like VLM conditioned on more
classical computer vision stuff like, I
don't know, any kind of map of the
environment or like what is the most
promising direction would you say?
Yeah, great question. I think, you know,
breaking this into research versus like
technology. I think for research
direction we talk about foundation
models, right? I think the
ethos there is not to use you know,
let's say a slam mapping or different
vision techniques of, you know,
especially like localization or things
like that. Let's not use them as a black
box at test time. Let's just distill
those capabilities into the model
itself, right? If there was an
algorithm, a system, a software stack
that could do a very specialized to do
certain capabilities, let's just get the
foundation models to also do it itself.
That's one view. I think it's more like
curious about the science itself of like
anything that humans were able to write
or create as an engineered system or as
a specialized, you know, model that we
trained, then the general should be able
to do that too under some kind of
resourcing and compute and scale. But I
think, you know, for the
commercialization, for the real world
deployment,